now before I ask you to sit down if any
of the gentlemen would like to remove
their jackets please feel free to do so
from then on please be seated
all right good evening good evening
members and officers of the council and
members of the press on public I welcome
you to this meeting of the council first
we will go through the fire procedure if
the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs I have
through the security doors to my right
or opposite the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lifts please
assemble in holy square on the green on
the green officers will assist you and
advise when it is deemed safe to return
to the chamber the Proceedings of the
meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet I
would advise that the filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their image captured I
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
Oh quite a few do
right okay any member of the public who
objects to the possibility of being
filmed may wish to take this opportunity
to leave the meeting any filming or
recording will not be permitted for any
item of business where exempt or
confidential information is considered
following the exclusion of the press and
public from the meeting would everyone
present please ensure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent and that
they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber while this
meeting is in progress
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
apologies were received from the
following councilors Glenn Coleman cook
councillor Edwards councillor Sarah
Larkins and councillor
Beverly Martin's are there ever any
other apologies councillor Rogers I know
that the minutes of the meeting of the
annual Council held on the 11th of May
2017 be approved and signed as a correct
record would the lead at please second
second another to do members agree
right now I've got a very pleasant job
to do what counselors do counselor ever
in a suit Piper please make his way to
the tape top table please
please will members be upstanding while
I present the past Chairman's budge it
gives me great pleasure to present you
with the past Chairman's badge and I'm
sure members will join me in thanking
you for your work representing the
council as chairman over the past two
years and it is a pleasure Stewart I
think you did a really super job well
I'm chairman thank you very much
officers and members the pressing public
as well it was an honor and a privilege
and I thank him for this recognition
thank you very much please be seated
thank you very much
are there any declarations of interest
agenda item number five two petitions
have been received and two petitions
returns to Council in accordance with
council procedure rule number 12 please
note that the council's Constitution
permits up to 30 minutes for the
consideration of petitions an e petition
containing 39 valid signatures has been
received by the council I am pleased to
welcome mr. combs to the meeting could
you please make your way to the top
table he's not here all right
yeah in accordance with the council's
petition scheme the petition will be
referred to cabinet without debate for
report to the council within three
ordinary meetings okay agenda item
number five petition regarding cleanup
cliftonville West and a petition
containing a hundred and eighty-two
valid signatures has been received by
the council I am pleased to welcome mrs.
Goodison to the meeting would you please
make your way to the top table
[Applause]
mrs. Goodison you have three minutes to
speak as I'm aware that many counsellors
don't live in the ward of Cliftonville
West could I distribute some photographs
which illustrates my three minute speech
okay thank you and I'm here as a
resident of cliftonville West and also
as a representative of a Besser
Cliftonville a resident led community
group where litter and it fly-tipping
and its negative effects is top of the
agenda at every meeting
despite ABC forming a waste form with
sanik District Council the streets
clifftops and beaches of Cliftonville
remain strewn with litter blighted by
dog fouling and in a general state of
neglect with missing bin lids inadequate
infrastructure and no positive messages
being sent to the community around
caring for the environment this neglect
has a huge impact on residents
businesses and visitors to the area do
you think it is acceptable that the
people of Cliftonville should live with
streets that fall well below Deborah's
lowest grade of cleanliness counselors
have a duty to ensure that the land
under their control is kept clear of
litter and refuse a significant cause of
this continual stream of Lissa is the
municipal and private bins left without
lids often for months on end
inadequate bin allocation and
collections especially for HMOs and
street cleaners never actually cleaning
the residential streets we are
constantly told in ABC meetings that
there are not the funds to carry out bin
audits nor the stock to replace lips nor
the resources to litter pick weed or
clean the streets but this is not
acceptable litter and dog fouling
contaminate surface water which runs
into the sea
adding to the poor water quality reading
at war
hobb a pavement drains are blocked by
weeds and detritus which has built up
over months if not years local
businesses are left with negative
feedback due to cut the unacceptable
state of the area put enough potential
visitors to Cliftonville and bring him
morale down cliftonville west according
to the most recent government index of
multiple deprivation survey ranks in the
bottom 1% of the most deprived areas in
the country cliftonville has the
greatest population density of any
warden Cantor Medway with high density
low standard housing and high levels of
anti-social behavior why are we adding
to this reports from local enforcement
agency Kingdom Keep Britain Tidy and the
list of strategy for England state that
litter is one of the first signs of
social decay we know that people are
more likely to drop litter if the
environment is already littered and
people who live in a poor quality
environment are more likely to suffer
for mental health problems due to
anxiety and depression a clean
environment sends a signal that dropping
litter is not socially acceptable TDC
completely pointless rings resonating
music addition you need to get okay
you've heard your three minutes thank
you so the solutions local community
groups and individual is wrecked
individuals regularly cific and Street
clean themselves because the situation's
become so intolerable but this barely
scratches the surface the litter
strategy for England has three clear
solutions education the council should
display numerous large highly visible
clear and simple signs instructing
people to put mothers in the bins main
infrastructure mrs. Middleton I'm sorry
you've had your time I think you need to
finish
I'm very nearly at the end I can really
wind up yeah so infrastructure increase
the amount of bins make sure that are
accessible and secure and enforcement
use powers to enforce fines to send a
clear message to the community we love
cliftonville we love the vibrant
community we need more help than all the
other areas of Fannett
it's been neglected for so long we ask
you the counselors to change this and
help us make a cleaner healthier safer
and happier Cliftonville thank you mrs.
garrison
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme the petition will be
referred to cabinet without debate for
report to the council within three
ordinary meetings petition regarding
access to Hodges gap this item is to
report back
the council's response to the petition
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme would members please
note the report
thank you very much agenda item 5d
petition regarding 2017 parking charges
having been considered by the overview
and scrutiny panel and in accordance
with the council's petition scheme the
petition will now be referred to the
cabinet thank you very much does anybody
want to debate this councillor Campbell
I thought you chair yes obviously this
was debated at the Uyuni committee and
the ovule scrutiny committee recommended
that the charges be reverted back to the
last year's right which I'm sure
enthused the cabinet no end what has
happened I understand is a wholly new
report has now been raised that hasn't
been seen by overview and scrutiny and
will be looked at at the cabinet an
extraordinary cabinet we one gender item
on the 18th this is a sort of voucher
scheme that addresses the issue for
parking charges for residents but of
course doesn't address the issue for
visitors and tourists who still will
have to pay easy four-pound as it's this
new scheme I understand will be
self-financing now perhaps the lead-up
could inform me if on the 18th ah well I
can't believe it to be true but only
18th the new scheme is okayed and passed
by the Cabinet does this nullify the
overview and scrutiny recommendation
that will be determined or decided on
the 27th thank you
I do have some parts of my leaders
report which makes comment on on this
particular area you're asking me for a
legal opinion effectively on the way the
two decisions into play my understanding
is that cabinet is the decision-making
board here they've Kevin Bacon sitting
on the 18th and that is
we'll go forward I'm sure I will be
corrected if that's wrong
all right thank you very much
right agenda item number six question
from the press and public one question
has been received from a member of the
public in accordance with council
procedure rule number 13
please note it's only the questioner and
respondent are permitted to speak on the
question and that if the questioner is
not present at this meeting their
question cannot be be put but will
replug bit work but will be replied to
in writing could the questioner please
only state the name of the cabinet
member to whom their question is to be
put and read out the exact wording of
the question that they submitted to the
council agenda item 6a question number
one from a member of the public
cleanliness of Cliftonville West would
members please refer to the sakai
supplementary agenda number one I am
pleased to welcome mrs. Buddhism back to
the meeting could you please make your
way to the top table
you've got three minutes following on
from the petition submitted regarding
the very poor level of cleanser
cleanliness of the streets and beaches
and cliftonville west can the cabinet
member responsible answer why no
adequate measures have been taken to
address this when will a suitable plan
and schedule be put in place Thank You
missus Goodison I call upon councillor
brim to respond Thank You mr. chairman
I'm just about to brief out a lot of
what we do so the council is and so the
members of a better cliftonville so if
you can just wait until those councilors
ask me the questions I can give you your
information
well she needs to answer the question
yeah
yeah I'm intent I'm tempting to pick the
answer those issues in question for
about service delivery with Cliftonville
counselor brim you need to you need to
respond to the question please okay
right cleansing the litter bins are
emptied in Cliftonville West at least
three to four times a day 7 days a week
compared to one or two times a day
district white white 30% of the
cleansing teams resources are dedicated
to cliftonville West Ward
approximately 3,000 properties which are
50% of total properties still receive a
weekly domestic waste collection there
are currently 830 issues selective
licenses relating to properties within
the cliftonville West Ward 40
enforcement notices 204 breaches of
condition notices have been served in
respective dwellings within the ward in
Cliftonville West a large majority have
been around inadequate waste storage
since April 2016 2 landlords have been
prosecuted who have had properties
within Ward for failing to apply for
selective license since April 2016 we've
carried out 51 selectively license
inspections since April 2016 and
cliftonville west which includes
providing sufficient and suitable
containers for waste with regards to
what you have said
weeds are one of the your Kent County
counselors jobs that falls within KCC
that doesn't fall within my remit so
weeds in cliftonville if you have
problems with weeds you need to be
concepts in your paint county council
representatives bin lives we have a guy
that is going around replacing bin lids
on a regular occasion he is on to the
job it is a bit like repainting the
fourth bridge because by the time he's
finished doing them he has to start
doing them all over again so
[Music]
well I've just said that actually
cliftonville West does receive due to
the demographics a more enhanced service
than other areas because of that we're
working with Jean Reynolds is working
with the Walpole bay bathers Club she's
what
she's working on putting extra signage
down there which I think she's doing in
about fortnight's time that's to enhance
the water quality down at the Walpole
Bay I myself I'm running a personal dog
fouling campaign there's another officer
we've got three dog fouling campaigns on
the guy at the moment we've got
fly-tipping campaigns we tweets about
them we put them on Facebook we do okay
right so what I suggest you do is
because I've not received apart from the
Julie Taylor councillor jela della and
councillor Potts I have not received any
communication from Emma Dawson I don't
think it's contacted me once in 18
months so what I suggest the district
councillors use the policy of reporting
issues because if they're not using the
policy and reporting the issues - but
what are they doing system I'm not the
counselor for cliftonville West I'm
expecting the councillors to use the
policy whereby they report things to the
officers that are responsible and copy
their counselors in but at the moment
that's not happening thank you very much
councillor brim thank you very much mrs.
Goodison can i please ask for courtesy
in the public area while ever a
councillor is giving their response I
would expect you courtesy and quiet
thank you very much
reduce I'm sorry I'm going to move on we
have a lot we have a lot to cover
tonight if you are not going to if you
are not going to respect the council
then I will act I will ask for you to be
removed
would you please leave all right agenda
item number 7 questions from members of
the council six questions have been
received from members in accordance with
council procedure rule number 14 please
note that the time allowed for
consideration of questions from members
shall not exceed 30 minutes without the
leave of the chair this can only be
granted in exceptional circumstances so
I ask members to be succinct and to
avoid repetition where possible
I will if you want me to agenda item 7a
a question from question number one from
a member regarding housing
I call upon council a matter face Thank
You chair
my question is to cancel infinite bruss
Senate District Council recently issued
a very worrying report on the severity
of the housing situation long after
labor council has warned of a crisis in
housing were canceled of Fairbrass
support Labor's cold for a scrutiny day
where all agencies and elected members
can attend and share best practice I
call upon councillor Fabrice to respond
thank you madam chair I thank councillor
Matt's face for her question and I'm
pleased to note the Labour members of
this council recognized the housing
difficulties faced by many residents on
low incomes in this district we have not
issued a report recently but have been
very open about the scale of the
challenges facing residents and about
the work that the council has been doing
to support people in housing need
councillor matter face may be referring
to the article that appeared on the Isle
of Thanet news website on the 26th of
June the article gave an accurate
account to the scale of housing
pressures and of the underlying causes a
combination of the growing shortage of
affordable rented homes increasing
private Center rents and welfare benefit
reforms are making it increasingly hard
for people on low incomes to find the
homes they need we've responded to these
pressures by securing new funding for
housing and homelessness and setting up
new services with our local delivery
partners these new services include the
opening of the first Thanet worked
winter shelter and the new aspire
project to support rough sleepers we are
investing 28 million into the delivery
of a hundred and forty new and
refurbished affordable rented homes and
have secured 400,000 pounds for a new
Rapid Response Service to help prevent
homelessness for people struggling to
pay their
or keep their tenancies we are returning
more empty homes to use and taking
action to improve more private rented
sector homes than any other council in
Kent
we have successfully piloted a new rogue
landlords program and bid for funding to
continue that service these are
fantastic achievements considering the
restricted resources available to the
council but more is needed this year we
will predict leave producing a new
housing strategy for the district to
continue this work and set out our
priorities and ambitions we will involve
partner organizations in this work and
ensure that members of the overview and
scrutiny panel have an opportunity to be
involved members will know that there is
already an agreed process for proposing
reviews to the overview and scrutiny
panel which is the appropriate way to
put forward suggestions
do you have a supplementary question
councilman yes I do thank you I
understand from councillor Johnson that
the request for the scrutineer day has
in fact been turned down which I find
extremely disappointing I've got one
particular question which relates to the
52 social housing units which have
planning permission and funding under a
labor administration and yet today none
has been built could you please tell me
when those you there's much needed units
that you have referred to in your reply
to me when they are in fact going to be
built thank you
and the matter for the scrutiny day
would be for to present to this the
chairman of scrutiny I'm not able to
endure so it's 51 units of affordable
accommodation that I'm aware of Sussex
Street Ramsgate Wright's place ditches
to Road Clements Road Kingston close and
Lancaster close Perkins Avenue
Norman Road Prince Andrew Road
Broadstairs Princess Anne Road
Broadstairs we have been out to tender
for these as far as I know timescales
our Sussex Street the timescale that we
are giving is 20 August 2018 brights
place or was 2018 Chichester Road May
2018 these are the these are targets
basically hopefully they'll be within
that time Clements Road May 2018
Kingston and Lancaster closed March 2018
sorry May 2018 Perkins Avenue
November 2017 Norman Road November 2017
Prince Andrew Road November 2017 and
Princess Anne Road November 2017 they
are off there are our dates of
Thank You counselor Matt's face Thank
You counselor Fabrice agenda item 7b
question number two from a member
regarding sleeping and rubbish removal
in Margate central Ward I call upon
councillor Johnson thank you very much
chairman thank you and I'm it's a
question to councillor brim please
residents and myself and Margate central
constantly have to report the same areas
that need sweeping or rubbish removal
when will you walk the whole Ward with
residents and myself to see for yourself
our concerns thank you I called Punk
house councillor broom to respond Thank
You mr. chair right thanks councillor
Johnson for your question I'm pleased to
confirm that I'm happy to walk with the
officers in your wards if you make me
aware of the actual names of the streets
and we can take those issues up as the
councillor is aware we place
considerable cleaning and enforcement
resources into the Margate central Ward
on a daily and weekly basis 22
identified high footfall roads in
Margate central have received a weekly
mechanical clean as well as additional
daily manual cleans over the last few
months operational services managers
have walked hotspot areas with the
councillor they've also provided the
follower ditional cleaning activities on
top of the normal daily cleaning
services in her ward we've we've carried
out those activities with by deep
cleaning of Henry's alley on the high
street in Margate the Primark shop front
cleaning and jet washing Woolworths
frontage cleaning and jet washing
cleaning the alley to the rear of the
old cinema on the Margate High Street
additional cleaning of holy square on a
number of occasions and surrounding work
roads - included in John's Road Milton
and Byron additional cleaning - Dane
Hill twin trinity square plus alley rear
of the Margate caves areas of flats in
King Street have also been targeted
Margate high street a number of
additional cleans a further deep clean
has been arranged for the 28th of July
2017 around
so he'll which will include bulky waste
enforcement and street cleaning
activities in terms of the council
priority for a clean and welcoming
environments our enforcement team over
the last 12 months have issued 1750
fixed penalty notices for litter
offenses with over 1400 of them being
issued in Margate central we will also
be installing and upgrading litter bins
at the clock tower in Margate the offal
band stands to support the farmers
market and the users of the bandstand
palm bay shelter alongside the footpath
next to the shelter basically this this
is in response to what I'm saying is is
that I will quite happily walk your
wards but I will do it with the officers
at a time when it's convenient to me
councillor Johnson and not to you thank
you very much chairman I think that
members will draw their own conclusions
the list that's been read out by
councillor brim are exactly the areas
that I report constantly yes we have
mechanical sweepers that go along the
seafront but it's the side roads that we
constantly have to report and my
question yet again is which was first
given to several times last year in this
year I don't want you to walk just with
the officers I want you to meet the
residents that I have to talk to every
day and I want you to walk the ward with
me it is the first time in the history
of this council that a cabinet member
has refused to walk award with a
councillor I have always found both
conservative and Labour and any other
administration would walk the cabinet
member would come out to see what the
problem was you are the first councillor
to refuse to do so it is unacceptable
and it certainly doesn't reflect as can
we bring it to an end yes I'll bring it
to a question can I have a date when you
personally will agree to walk Margate
Central Ward with me and actually meet
the residents who again today talk to me
about the problems I've told them who
you are they do write to you and may I
say councillor Dawson I've seen you
all right now it's to John that's enough
Thank You June
do you want my son Elementary is for the
day - she's going to walk the ward with
me yes we're well aware of that
counselor Johnson would you like to
respond counselor brim yes counselor
Johnson if you send me an email again
highlighting the roads that have issues
I will walk the ward with the officers
right sorry chairman she doesn't answer
my emails it's very hard his room is
equipment not working agenda item 7c 17
yeah question number three from a member
regarding the council suite cleaning
schedule would members please refer to
the supplementary agenda number one for
the remaining questions
I call upon counselor Kane Gregory thank
you madam chairman question is could the
cabinet member for operational services
please tell me if the district councils
street-cleaning schedule for individual
areas is available for residents to
inspect and if so where may they see it
I call upon councilor bring to respond
Thank You chair well can I just tell
there's a by-election coming up hmm
this is currently councillor Gregory
being developed however basic cleaning
rounds information is on the council's
websites over the coming weeks a new map
and postcode lookup facility will be
added to make it more easy for residents
to find out when the cleansing teams
will be in their road Thank You
councillor Gregory do you have a
supplementary question surprisingly yes
madam chairman what I would ask is if
this schedule is going to be published
perhaps it would be a good idea if it
were placed with every individuals
council tax bill so that they knew when
to look out and see if their streets had
been swept or not
and by doing that we actually have the
most effective monitoring team in the
world ie our residents the people who
pay for the street-sweeping would you
like to respond to that councillor brim
thank you sure councillor Gregory the
what we're trying to do is try and
interact with the public a bit more so
we are publishing information on the
Flajnik district council websites about
our street cleansing rotors and that's
something that has not been done by any
previous administration so we're trying
to be a bit more a bit more creative the
way we go forward in communicating with
members of the public and informing them
when our street cleaners cleaners are in
their area thank you
gender item 7d question number four from
a member regarding education in sonnet
I call upon counselor Savage thank you
very much madam chairman I asked this
question because I feel it's very
topical at the moment address the
question to councilor hunt astonished
nursing education is an important part
of the corporate plan in attracting
businesses searching for a highly
skilled workforce the closure of the
university campus in Broadstairs is
therefore catastrophic
what plans is the cabinet member
formulating to counter the impact on the
future of so many of our young people
I call upon council wells to respond I
got to respond to that kind of savage
because I'm the person who's met with
the University of Rochester this week
okay
education is indeed a vital component to
promote him with investment and job
creation it's important that our schools
and colleges work together to bring
drive up standards abroad opportunities
that lead to good jobs and that's
increasingly difficult of course in an
environment where government is cutting
back on the funds they actually spend on
these areas but our schools and our
colleges do their best to actually work
that forward this council has already
signed a Memorandum understanding with
East Kent College to ensure that the
skills and economic growth agendas run
in parallel and we're proud to support
their work and we're delighted they're
deservedly being rated as outstanding by
Ofsted it would be nice to move forward
and assign the memory understanding you
can tap a Christchurch however I don't
think it would have been an appropriate
thing to do in the current climate and
given what they have done in terms of
closing or predicting to close they can
- across university additional campus
here at Ball says many of you would have
seen what I said publicly about that and
I met with the University
vice-chancellor again on Tuesday this
week and left him in no doubt about our
dismay and our dissatisfaction with that
decision and I do believe that as we
move forward we're going to be talking
with their senior Madren teens without
putting some real meat on their promise
to continue to assist students in this
area
and their work within within the
university sector and ensure that
whatever heritage vestige they're going
to leave behind actually does support
those disadvantaged students in the
local campus was such a large line
councillor savage do you have a
supplementary question I don't madam
chairman thank you thank you very much
agenda item 7e question number five from
a member regarding street cleaning
service standards
I call upon councillor Dawson thank you
madam chair
but the cabinet members operational
services confirmed that the service
standard for street cleaning for birch
in turn is the same for Cliftonville
West
I call upon councilor brain to respond
Thank You chair I can confirm the
councillor Dawson that more Street
cleaning services have been delivered
and cliftonville West in the last six
months than any other ward in the
district operational services also
working proactively in the wards as part
of the waste forum with ABC they are
working together on the following all
issues on cleansing that are raised in
the monthly waste forum at these
meetings residents raise concerns which
we respond to either with information
clarification or we take away actions to
try and resolve these issues you might
do well to attend some of those ABC
forums operational services are
supporting ABC with the lottery bids and
are helping them to deliver the project
involving a number of types of behavior
change experiments and resources for the
local community such as storage storage
units new signage and bins litter voting
bins wildlife houses and cleanup
equipment amongst other things such as
setting up a group of waste champions
deep-clean so far have been carried out
an ethylene Road and the surrounding
alleyways Godwin and Gordon roads have
been completed and there is one planned
for Swain Albion and Harold's Road in
September this year in response to ABC
requests operational services are
replacing all domestic Wilbon lives one
Road at a time in each ward
we have provided the will pay Walpole
bays swimmer group with two-minute beach
clean boards to use for their activities
around the coast in the area we targeted
cliftonville West Ward as part of the
four pilot up areas for our dog fouling
campaign we are all organizing other
cleanup activities in the world such as
the forthcoming love where you live
clean up with McDonald's on the 26th of
July operational services staff have
attended many community events such as
Cliftonville games and various others to
spread the waste messages and
information requests and educates with
the children and campaigns such as wise
up to waste Thank You councillor Dawson
do you have a supplementary question
thank you
sarcasm gets you nowhere councillor brim
but I would like to comment on this cut
the cabinet member tell me why it's
taken just over two years of you being
in office to maintain to fulfil your
priority to keep a clean and welcoming
environment as stated in your corporate
priorities and indeed in your election
pledge Thank You chair Henderson i'ma
tell you what does get you somewhere and
that's when you start acting a small
councillor and actually starts following
procedure and same email sorry I am NOT
going to tolerate any more sniping in
the council chamber please treats each
other up with courtesy okay okay 81
counselors at Kent County Council and
the Tories just voted for a 15%
allowance increase equates to a hundred
and fifty five thousand five hundred and
twenty pounds you are now the highest
came counter councillors in the whole of
the UK planets are only one area please
keep under the whole it's paid
councillors in the whole of the UK with
a hundred and fifty six thousand five
hundred and twenty pounds we could have
employed
seven roads sweepers three skate parks
three play areas I suggest now the
councillors stop acting
what you would be better doing is
donating your allowance
you'll pay rise today to local good
causes to local good causes
Pfizer red counters or any Mally's King
up top I know you've not sent me one
email in 18 months councillor brim
agenda item 7f question number 6 from a
member regarding the format Manston
airport site
I call upon councilor Beauford yeah
thanks
before I ask the question if I would
just be helpful to councilor brim just
to let you know you don't have causa
bedford will you please ask your
question this important show you don't
have to keep painting false bridge
anymore they've got new paint that lasts
forever apparently so you have to do
that now um the question is the leaders
recently commented favorably on the
prospect of a new potential investor
looking to pursue a cpr and respected
man stand there Paul can he explained
his enthusiasm for this given his
assertion that the ouvea report
demonstrates unequivocally that aviation
activity is not viable I call upon the
leader to respond thank you a question
I have generally expressed a preference
for an airport at Munson and SEO counsel
babies well over there have had several
conversations with several interested
parties on that subject it is a matter
of fact that the AG report commissioned
on behalf of this council in respect to
the local plan states in its in its
conclusions that an airport is not
viable during the plan period it is also
factually correct the ABE report was
unable to consider or access or assess
River Oaks plans factual content does
not mean I cannot express a preference
but in the final analysis whatever
happens at that site must offer serious
employment and economic opportunity for
planet residents as a whole counselor
but counsel Beauford do you have a
supplementary question other cheriya
thank you given today's news from the
planning inspector how does the lead to
think this should impact on the emerging
local plan the plan expected publish the
decision I think about hoppers 3d stuff
today and I really on the train back
from London obviously we all have to
look carefully at that in the context of
whatever else is going on it is a change
of you should for building the decision
and that is
only part obviously of what goes forward
into the local plan but whatever the
local prime locations are will be dealt
with by the local plan working group
which I believe you all remember
thank you agenda item number eight
motions on notice no motions on notice
have been received in accordance with
council procedure rule number three the
leaders report I call upon the leader
and thank you madam chairman I just
point out really for for those listening
that the needs report and the way it's
constructed into the Constitution starts
life on Saturday and is sort of
formalized by yesterday so the decisions
like was just referred to that came to
today are not liked even came within it
okay
I attended the LGA conference in
Birmingham last week where incidentally
I paid 19 pounds to park my car for 24
hours and for far fewer beaches and less
Sun new experience down here I also met
with anti-corruption campaign and Martin
Bell still a marvelous rocontour still
wearing that famous white suit he proved
the popular and welcome contributed to
the conference unlike I have to say qat
secretary Javid who in a few short
sentences managed to alienate everybody
in the room labour conservative
independent and everybody else he came
to life a trust from people in local
government since the grenfell fire which
given the government's lack of action
since 2010 over fire seems a little
harsh described by a Labour County at
the time as an exercise in blame
shifting and then asserted interests me
that local authorities were not building
enough homes and he will be increasing
housing numbers through local plan
targets in the coming weeks there was
huge frustration with this and even
conservative members were seething and
discussing walking out he then went home
without meeting with us because he had
to attend a vote in the House of Commons
near a home we've seen the for yoga
dreamland since the last meeting
following a 27 billion pound revamp new
rides of 15,000 audience concert with
the guerrillas whom my children tell me
are very popular is that right to
trending very common okay
trending across social media throughout
in the southeast these media recently
described Margate is one of the best
places to live in the country few maybe
perhaps would disagree though cliff to
the West might have some views and that
could indeed be comment from Ramsgate
many of whose residents may be rightly
more concerned with the safety and
maintenance of the royal harbor we
inherited a maintenance backlog for the
flat gates that keep Rams natural
harbour going and have obviously as
you'll see on these papers for tonight
looking at investing $3 million pounds
also to keep it functioning this is an
addition to the maintenance backlog
preventing ships coming back to Ramsgate
port in addition to the infamous selling
of the freehold of Ramsgate seafront and
the teeth of local opposition by a
Margate councillor it will perhaps be
fair to say that under labor that
Ramsgate versus Margate divided existed
under you kit we're at least trying to
address it in your beat in a gradual
manner a further issue which has
attracted attention is the price of
seasonal car parking in a small number
of our many car blocks this has been
scrutiny reviewed as council the
Campbell reminders a little earlier on
which reports back to full council under
the Constitution in plier to cabinet who
actually hold the power of decision this
came from petition based upon the first
few weeks of the new charges showing a
dip in parking income a dip that we
discover is commonplace amongst all Kent
councils to increase charges in April
and May it always been our intention to
introduce dual fee parking where
residents can if possible be encouraged
to further use our high streets and
local assets to lower parking charges
than those that tourists the visitors
may pay we have been able to achieve
this as the investment requires quite
expensive and PR automatic number plate
recognition technology and this crew
beyond the financial investing
capability of a council left weakened
financially by decisions of previous
administrations however with a little
creative thinking we can use these car
parks to test the principle of dual fees
which we found to be popular with
residents on the Dorset and for those
who thought that the car park income
reduction would be a permanent feature
we saw an increase in party income from
the seasonal car part those seasonal car
parts alone from 51,000 in June 2016 to
91,000 in June 2017 the dip would appear
together in the proposed changes and
charges bring big
discounts to residents and they'll be
laid before cabinets has discussed
earlier next week recent weeks have also
seen consultation undertaken by River
Oaks strategic partners regarding their
putative DCO RSP is obliged to consult
with tannic Council as the host
authority for any DC application and the
council welcomes this engagement deseos
comes under the planning act 2008 and
our executive function which means legal
authority of these matters rests with
the executive not full council which is
why RSP are being asked to consult with
the cabinet and senior council officers
indeed it will be unlawful for full
council to deal with this matter since
under the Local Government Act 2000 any
function which is responsibility of an
executive of a local authority may not
be discharged by the full council Dover
District Council interesting enough when
dealing with DC Oh actually deseos in
relation to their own functions but
actually delegate them to a senior
officer in order to enable swift
responses and not involving politicians
through those decisions at all other
authorities can deal differently because
they are not the host Authority our
report back to Future Council on
progress in matters relating to the
Manson Airport site even perhaps this
afternoon's news the local plank to to
use progressed slowly given it should
have been in place in 2011 it does give
some protection from developer incursion
onto unallocated sites as right now with
no local plan in place there is limited
protection for any green space across
our island it should also be noted that
the local plan debate seems to become a
little stuck in a straitjacket of
housing versus airport which is a
pretense we will still be required to
allocate sites for housing under the
government systems whether the airport
site is mixed use or aviation use if the
airport site is returned to aviation
only use then alternative sites will
have to be found once again for the
houses currently offered for that site
and the truth is when developers talk to
possible sites to us in the last soft
cycle and process it was around birches
and Westgate and the villages that they
were most interested and most
enthusiastic in addition if River Oaks
predicted employment figures are
accurate then further housing must be
added still according to the formula if
jobs spread worldwide across East Kent
in the southeast and other cancers may
yet have to increase their housing
as well plus as stated earlier community
secretary conservative Sajid Javid
community's Minister is telling us yet
more houses likely be added to
government demands these are not council
requirements or calculations but
Conservative government calculations to
which you are required to adhere in
producing our local plan we have
suffered several traveler incursions in
recent weeks some on private land some
on public land and some threatening in
manner the current local plan has no
permanent traveler site in the district
and I should add that the recent
planning application regarding a small
aside is nothing to do with the council
I must go through the planning system
for proper decision it was a real
sadness that I heard the decision of
Canterbury Christ Church University
regarding the future of the Broadstairs
campus legislation demands we consider
the Equality impacts of any intended
change and this decision would seem to
impact those who can least afford a
university education the limited impact
on those from middle class backgrounds
whose judgment on their university is is
about social as well as educational
experience contrasts sharply with the
strong impact upon those whose decision
to attend university may have been
marginal those whose parents worry about
death single parents who value the role
of a local campus and library closer to
home
those who studies are squeezed between
working long izing care homes and
supermarkets to make ends meet that's it
and the university alone is not to blame
the level of student fees now levied is
a lifelong cost against students casting
a university education as a consumer
good brings with it a different
expectation of university life the
university sector have embraced tuition
fees and they have ensured that that
suffer far less as a sector than other
publicly funded bodies in the years of
austerity and the plethora of shiny new
buildings in university towns is
testament to that in truth it would seem
to have simply increase the gap between
richer university towns and others such
is the legacy and is often forgotten of
Labor's introduction of tuition fees and
touring manipulation of their size and
cost I have been in London today
presenting the council's contribution to
a conference on tackling rogue landlords
alongside officers Bob Porter and
Richard Hopkins we explain the positive
impacts of selective licensing and how
additional players have contributed to
our control
of the worst activities of rogue
landlords councils and public will also
wish to know that following the grand
troll tower fire we have checked for our
buildings and those rumbles can housing
on our behalf to ensure the residents
are indeed as safe as possible there is
more the difficulties of social care for
an aging population underfunded
nationally but particularly here in
conservative Kent where fee rates the
care homes are amongst the lowest in the
country
achieving preference to score places
where the failure of conservative run
Kent County Council to properly
coordinated missions policies as
required by law has borne particularly
heavily this year on the children in
Minster you know Conservative government
who have abolished the right support
grant for local government promising
full retention of business rates but
within the Queen's speech there's no
finance bill to make this happen
putting further downward pressure on
local authority stretched budgets
whatever is promised elsewhere whatever
he's talked about elsewhere an early end
to austerity looks very unlikely in the
context of local government
I commend this report to the council on
its concerns and look forward to comment
on other leaders Thank You councils
I call upon council be fit to comment on
or ask questions in relation to the
leaders report thank you thank you
leader for your report which is usual
with big on self-congratulation and full
of sideswipes at other political parties
firstly I welcome the good news that
Dreamland reopening was a great success
I'm sure we're all behind that and made
longer may that long continue um it's
also good to hear that our housing stock
appears to be free of the fire hazards
which led to the terrible Granville
tower disaster as far as engagement with
River Oak is concerned I don't think
anyone is contesting that full council
should deal with DCO rather than cabinet
what is in dispute though is whether RSP
should have the opportunity to present
their evidence with regard to the
potential of a revived Madison Airport
to fall Council who will be responsible
for approving the local plan what I find
perhaps more interesting are a couple of
things that you've left out of your
report that have happened since you last
reported to us there's been two
elections since you last reported
and I believe that they both demonstrate
clearly that both nationally and locally
you kit would become irrelevant in the
general election counts the piper polled
just six percent of the vote
although this is a good result by
YouTube's standards as 337 of their
candidates lost their deposits at the
county elections
you keep lost every seat it held but
perhaps the most telling statistic
leader was your own result standing in
an area that you've represented for
years you took just 13% of the vote 87%
of those who voted didn't want you which
is hardly a ringing endorsement of your
leadership of this council you refer to
the local plan being in a housing versus
Airport straightjacket but I don't think
that's the case the issue is that
Manston is designated for aviation use
in the current local plan you've
contended that an airport isn't viable
and the site should be used for housing
many people believe that the airport is
viable and that the DCO process in the
background will demonstrate this and as
a result many feel that the current
designation should remain and further as
a member of the cabinet advisory group
considering the emerging local plan I
can assure members that there were
plenty of potential sites to meet our
housing target without using the airport
what really surprised me was to hear you
suggest that successful airport was a
bad thing as the extra jobs provided
would only lead to more houses being
needed that's a totally shocking
assertion coming from the leader of a
district blighted for so many years by
absolutely terrible above average levels
of unemployment for that thought alone
counts the world you should listen to
your lecturer and consider your position
thank you call upon the leader to
respond thank you I just love it when
you say to me no I really shouldn't
spend too much time talking about other
people and then proceed to call for 85
percent of your own time yeah thank you
that I didn't realize I was that
important but there you are I could
spend several minutes correcting your
assertions but you know I don't think
you're probably
listening so we'll leave it at that I
call upon counselor Matta face to
comment on ask questions in relation to
the leaders reports thank you madam
chair I unfortunately didn't get the
expanded version I just got 10 topics
and I've only actually seen the script
this evening so I've had to hastily go
through it make a few points the first
point they're not actually in order so I
do apologize as they came to me the land
for the Senate campus I understand was
donated to Christchurch by phthalic
district council so could I ask are
there any covenants on the land that
would restrict its use to education my
second point was I understand inverse
Senate hit the chair of invest Alec has
resigned and bearing in mind the
importance of invest a little in
attracting inward investment could I ask
when a new chair will be appointed and
also when the committee will be
reconvened because I think they might
have a role to play in the further use
of the thonic campus you mentioning
permits parking permits for residents it
would be interesting to know will these
be up buy a badge or will they be the
paper permits where you have to scratch
how much time you're going to be parked
and where will they be available because
it could be people marching up and down
broad stairs High Street runs gate high
street or any other high street looking
for some we're selling the permits or
with regard to the parking costs I know
from people who've contacted me many
businesses in Thanet particularly in
Broadstairs Andrew Ramsey 8 have told me
that their businesses are suffering due
to the higher parking charges I suspect
part of that problem is the perception
that all the parking charges have
escalated when in actual fact it is as
we know it's seasonal car parks
you mentioned selective licensing I
would like to ask when we can see that
rolled out across Thanet because we know
there are properties that could benefit
from that you mentioned high street
parking in passing without going into
great detail I just like to toss into
the mix here a well-known court case
that might be worth taking on board if
you're thinking about whacking up
parking charges on the high street that
is at field and others versus the London
borough of Barnet it might be as well to
bear that in mind when you're looking at
high street charges thank you I call
upon the leader to respond okay thank
you that no I did apologize before
because everybody else seemed to gather
at port and I you know I have no
explanation sweating there so I will
simply set your points and if any occur
to you afterwards please do get in touch
as I stand here tonight I can't tell you
whether that land has covenants on it or
not the donation I will check and reply
to him writing yes we are going to be
looking for a new charity best talents
and it may well have a a vital role to
play in what we need to do is to move
forward and I hope that CC canticle she
is going to be part of that process
rather than actually I save themselves
off into Canterbury thirdly purpose
Rosalind I understand it they are stick
and peel rather like the current one
yeah stick and peel so eat and they will
be available online by post in the
gateways 9:00 we will be ensuring before
they are made available assuming the
cabinet approves this on Tuesday yeah so
that's ready to go for the main holiday
season at the end of July onwards and
you know to be able to park for to kind
of fit to the day in those five car
parks what we're talking about where it
might be important to residents yes
there is the perception that's grown up
this revised walk our parks we doesn't
just the seasonal ones they look at
Broadstairs for example the main car
parks down near the seafront
ah touch the seasonal car parks but you
know for a few minutes walk up by the
station you can actually offer the same
old theme park through all year long
selective licensure so I've been I said
I've been to this conference in London
on rogue landlords today and and it's
quite interesting we were comparing a
Bob also I was sat in comparing what
we've been able to do as a Rose would be
small district council then here at our
corner of Kent with Bristol City Council
who are an enormous ly bigger Authority
and I've been running something similar
and do not seem to achieved half as much
on three or four times the budget we've
done before and one of the reasons why
is that actually we have actually
focused on a particular area and make
changes in the area which as we've heard
in other descriptions tonight is the
area that seems most in need of help we
did look at the time of renewing the
selective loss of seeing at East live
audience gate we didn't actually come up
with the right statistics to justify
actually moving the scheme over there
but we have moved the use of the Margit
task force over to be part of what goes
on there so that we can assist where we
can short of selective licensing and
finally I am aware of that judgment I am
aware of this screen the income of on
and off street parking and we will bear
it in mind thank you I call upon
councillor Grove to comment on or ask
questions in relation to the leaders
report here thank you madam chairman
really nothing to add because the
questions I was going to ask was about
the permit parking and has been covered
by the leader and the last question
thank you Thank You councillor growth
agenda item ten report of the chairman
of the overview and scrutiny panel
I call upon councillor David Saunders to
present his report thank you chairman
members I'll keep it brief since my
annual report on the 22nd of March the
overview and scrutiny panel has met on
two occasions being 25th of April and
the 23rd of May in addition to the
overview and scrutiny panel meetings the
corporate performance review working
party met on the 27th of June whilst the
Community Safety Partnership Working
Party are scheduled to meet on the 20th
of July and the Dreamland working party
on the 31st of July can you note that in
the report which is fully comprehensive
for this evening can you please look at
for point to where the date of the
meeting should be the 15th of August not
the 18th of August and also members can
I just
through the following agenda item agenda
item 11 which covers the continuation of
the public speaking at committee
meetings trial which we've been working
on and take-up has been disappointing
but it's it's still there and in the
spirit of openness and transparency
I trust that members will support the
proposal when we get on to the next
agenda item thank you Thank You
councillor Saunders agenda item 11
oh sorry counts to Johnson
sorry chair I have a question for
councillor Saunders I'm always pleased
he was very courteous to me when I
contact him but I did actually ask other
people within the council in February
2016 that we must look at something to
help the homeless people with mental
health problems and others and then when
we had a scrutiny training day I was
delighted that we were told we could
have a scrutiny inquiry day so I asked
then probably about June of last year
could we do this and I was told let's
wait and see what happens with the
winter shelters which you know didn't
reach all of the people that I know in
my ward that desperately need support at
night they were still sleeping rough so
it continued and working with a lot of
organizations and agencies implanted
over many years I've been asked about
more joined up working and I know the
officers work very hard to I'm not in
any way criticizing but the reason I
asked from a scrutiny inquiry day as
recommended on our training day was that
all agencies would be in one room here
on the same day where they could talk
privately to each other about the
failures they think they see that they
tell us as counselors but they don't
seem to get across to people within the
council I asked for that inquiry day I
filled in the form which actually is a
bit ambiguous because it asks you the
same question a couple of times and you
have to kind of answer it the answer I
got really was and planky officer would
you do your best
scrutiny of the proposed topic is
unlikely to result in improvements for
local people with scrutiny of the issues
that I
raised would certainly improve issues
for local people all of them and I'm
talking right across the board whether
they're homeless whether they're rough
sleepers mental health difficulties and
I'm very very disappointed having waited
well over a year I still didn't get that
inquiry day that I asked for the labor
group were now thinking of having a
seminar counselor Johnston could you
please get to the point the point is
very clear I've been refused to have a
scrutiny inquiry day which we were told
on our training day that we should have
the point is very clear to me there are
desperate people within walking distance
of this council who wanted me to do this
and I've been turned down councillor
Saunders would you like to respond to
that yes certainly councillor Johnson's
absolutely right she filled in the
application form which goes through
democratic services unfortunately it's
not within my gift to assemble that
meeting the way that the forum proposed
I don't have the authority to summon all
councillors to a meeting and indeed I
don't have the authority to summon the
agencies specifically I went back and
asked for questions and you've raised
that one question in your response which
had we seen that on the forum and that
was to do with the success of the
Windsor shelter then we could have we
could have assembled a scrutiny
committee around that question but
really we need specific questions we
need to understand the objection of the
objectives of the day and unfortunately
as I said right at the start is not
within my gift as chairman to allow that
to happen without it going through
democratic services and all of the
aspects in respect of the scrutiny role
within this council to be looked at
sorry
Thank You councillor Saunders councillor
Campbell did you have a question yes
thank you very much sure it's to do with
the poor response as councillor Saunders
has mentioned - public speaking over and
scrutiny panel I believe this is because
it's probably too prescriptive
I think the members of the public
to give certain days notice prior to
being able to speak my suggestion let
over you scrutiny and I don't have this
to be taken on board this is a question
to councillor Saunders was that where
there are no residents who have gone
through that prescriptive process if
there are members present at the
overview and scrutiny panel who on the
night would wish to say speak on that on
a particular topic for a given period of
time and obviously very limited and very
rigorously monitored bothered by the
chair they should be allowed to do so I
just wondered if that's now included in
the public speaking protocol for of you
know scrutiny or we're still looking at
the prescriptive method which seems as
used as the curve the chair said is
being less than successful thank you
Thank You councillor Campbell I think
you will see that this refers to the
next item agenda item 11 public speaking
it overview and scrutiny panel meetings
oh do you want to respond councillor
Saunders I do indeed councillor
Campbell's
a very worthy member of my panel and he
will know that I can be very generous
when it comes to my position and I am
more than happy and I do have the gift
of allowing exactly what councilor
Campbell has asked for as long as the
approach is made before the meeting and
as long as it's a prepared question and
it complies with the free minute rule
yes if it's suitable and it makes sense
and it adheres to the agenda then I'm
happy to take that on board thank you
Thank You councillor Saunders agenda
item 11 public speaking at overview and
scrutiny panel meetings I move that
council adopts the draft public
participation scheme is outlined in
annex one of the reports and amends the
council's Constitution as outlined at
annex two of the report would the leader
please second second Mullen chairman
with the chair of scrutinies blessing
do members agree thank you
madam chairman I would have liked to say
something on that item but unfortunately
couldn't I don't know whether you allow
it or not yeah councillor Smith thank
you very much madam chairman I would
just like to say that really I'm very
much in favor of public speaking at any
council meeting that is able to invite
members of the public in and I do think
to show that TDC is open and outward
looking it is very important I know
we've had a poor take up to date but I
do think it's important that we have
opportunities for residents to actually
contribute by asking questions and
sharing their views with us I don't
think this should just be for overview
and scrutiny actually I would like to
encourage members to think of this
perhaps at cabinet meetings certainly
planning you can speak at the moment as
we know and I do hope that this pilot
scheme um has has already been voted on
will actually be endorsed and the
Constitution will be amended to reflect
this thank you and I'm sorry I didn't
have a chance to speak before the vote
thank you
Thank You councillor Smith
agenda item 12 amendment to the pay
policy statement 2017-18 I move that
council approves the amended pay policy
statement for the 2017 18 as set out in
annex 1 of the report after which it
will be published would the leader
please second second dimension
councillor Gregory I must get my glass
has changed Thank You chair I've just
got a query on some of the amended
wording in here we had the non-statutory
chief executives chief officer sorry
director shared services appointments
what it said previously was that salary
on appoint will be approved by the
general purposes can we see down in 4.15
it says this will be made by a decision
be made by the general purposes
committee what we have now is an
appointment panel comprised of members
now if that's meant to be just exactly
as it says it could be one or two
members of that committee and I'd like
to know really why we're changing that
from the actual committee of about what
is it six leg members something like
that to just one or two and also how we
would select those one or two think of
jokey ions and that's current practice
it's not generally it's not Leslie all
the members of the general purposes
committee and practice it can be a
smaller number of those members so
that's why the change has been proposed
because that reflects current practice
as I understood it
I think the point that's being made is
when you having a run recruitment
process it's highly unusual to have
eight people actually participating in
an interview process so this concept is
quite common in the sense that a
selection of people from general
purposes committee form an interview
panel I think that's generally the
purpose of that reference as I
understand it so so can we know then how
we would select those members I mean is
it just going to be you know officers
choice or volunteers or what no the
general purposes committee itself would
decide which of its members would form
that selection panel so they decide to
say that I absolutely agree with the
answer the trouble is the wording
doesn't reflect the answer and we
changed the wording and so they didn't
reflect the answer to go back to the
answer we started with and so yeah it
goes actually the general purpose of
committee selected a small sub committee
to do it which would be perfectly normal
practice we now say members if we mean
the general purpose committee is still
selector smalls that's all going to do
it then I think the word you should
reflect that
yeah I'll amend it to clarify to make me
set subject to that any amendments dual
members agree thank you agenda item 13
changes to Committees of panels and
boards 2017-18 would members please
refer to supplementary agenda number one
proportionality I call upon the leader
to make a proposal in respect of the
options as outlined in the report I like
to propose the option outlined in
reports I believe there is only one
option one is there a second but does
any member wish to propose an
alternative option
don't members okay Carol council
Partington thank you madam chairman and
I might admit I think I'm missing some I
was very big and I might be missing
something but I can't find that on the
agenda
it's in Supplementary agenda pack is in
the main agenda oh it's in the main
agenda Pike yeah do you remember sorry
thank you nomination of members to serve
on committees broad leaders should take
this opportunity to advise of any change
to their nominations to committees
panels and board for the remainder of
2017 and 18 I call upon the leader a lot
to propose changes are dedicated in the
report which I believe their names are
okay formally cancer Jay Jones now
cancer exactly on playing playing subs
Standards Committee for me counselor Jay
Jones now councillor Stewart Piper cross
you should review formally counselor Joe
Jones now councillor Zeki
over in scrutiny formally councillor Jay
Jones now councillor Stewart Piper and
government an audit is currently still a
gap as these corporate performance
working party local plan working party
Council Chair Jones formerly uh now
councillor Piper thank you I call upon
councillor David
I'm not sure why you're calling me I'm
sorry I'm singing song do it's not - you
really are council matter face have you
got any yes I have there's planning sup
taking myself off and cancel the
Campbell will be the reserved for the
planning committee thank you alright
thank you very much
can we elect a vice chairman of the
planning committee
please rose-color so Jeremy fair recipes
well second are there any further
nominations as there are no further
candidates I declare that councillor
Jeremy Fabrice has been elected vice
chairman of the Planning Committee for
the remainder of 2017 18 agenda item 14
report to the council Ramsgate harbour
in a basin dock gate and lifting bridge
proposed refurbishment works the purpose
of this item is only to inform council
that this individual cabinet member
decision was treated as urgent in
accordance with paragraph 4 of the
budget and policy framework procedure
rules and was exempt from calling in
accordance with the overview and
scrutiny procedurals whilst members can
debate the decision-making process the
substantive decision cannot be debated
with members plead counselor
Gregory not a question on the decision I
learned my lesson last time I thank you
but just on the actual report which is
for information and I think if there's a
bit of information missing which would
be useful to us I think it's worth
bringing it up corporate implications
says that the 750 thousands come from
capital receipts reserves now when we
debated the capital program early on in
the year it was shorter funds and we
were told this was going to come from
the capital receipts reserve when the
money came into it can we know that this
won't this decision won't have any
impact on the capital program and that
there is plenty of money coming into the
capital reserves to cover all of these
eventualities now
Thank You Jay I think in the words of
our Kayla we will do our best
yeah council combo yeah Thank You chair
yes along the same lines as a councillor
Gregory 750 thousand pound investment in
Ramsgate harbour is worth its most
welcome
can you uh can you inform you as to
whether or not this 750 thousand capital
spend is being used from the receipt of
the sale of the freehold of pleasure
Armour as cancer Campbell knows that
item is held separately for the moment
should we find ourselves in difficulties
that councillor Gregory outlined we may
have to temporarily borrow from that and
repay but it will still be there for the
Tama gets the end of the process would
members please note the report thank you
and that concludes the business for this
meeting of the council